so um
as i said in the mueller it's always
about the supreme court right i mean
this is something conservatives have
gotten for the longest time they play
the long game they knew this from the
beginning it's about getting the court
that's where the power is they put six
catholics on the court i'm not going to
blame you personally andrew because
you're catholic and you defend catholics
but i blame it on you
i think you're giving the republicans
more credit than they deserve in this it
was luck to some extent if hillary
clinton had won in 2016 this wouldn't
have happened if ruth bader ginsburg had
resigned and retired when she should
have this probably wouldn't have
happened
this is trump adding three people to
this court
that's his real legacy
but it could have happened even with
just the person that should have been
merrick garland
it could have happened they've been
trying to and if it wasn't this time it
would have been the next time they play
the long game and they know how to win
and they did but if hillary had won she
would have appointed 3-2 and that it
would have been completely different so
there's a lot of contingency here well
republicans don't play purity politics
the way that those of us on the left do
as you mentioned in your monologue rusty
bowers this guy whose life was almost
ruined by donald trump still said that
he would vote for donald trump because
for him that principle was more
important than the individual whereas
those of us on the left are looking for
the perfect candidate and there is no
perfect candidate and so a lot of people
stay home and this is what you get
so what are we gonna
[Music]
so what are we going to do now that
we're we're basically living in like two
different countries i mean you know
there are countries in the world like
this israel certainly comes to mind
it's sort of you know almost officially
an apartheid country it could become one
um
belgium i mean i don't
you know i'm a defender of israel i
don't mean that's their fault
but it's a complicated situation belgium
you know they hate each other the
balloons and the flanders or whoever
they are but they don't talk
czechoslovakia divided like you take
slovakia we'll take check
but america can't do that but we're
going to be living in that kind of
country we've always lived in that
country
it's federalism if you think that
alabama is always going to have the same
politics as illinois or oregon you know
but just so we can really devolve these
decisions to the states that's the
genius of the american system there
doesn't have to be one consistent
national opinion on everything and we go
crazy we're just about opinions we're
talking about laws well the problem is
that the pendulum is swinging further
and further to the left and the right so
every time the right passes some
draconian bill whether it is about
abortion or trans kids or something like
that the left goes and does the opposite
there's no center there's no
there's no center there's what you write
about often
and i mean
america until today was the only western
country to have abortion as a
constitutional right
no other not even canada not germany nor
any of the other liberal countries they
did it by democratic rule and the
congress could do it today if they
wanted to pass a law saying abortion is
illegal in illegal in every state but
they don't have the votes because this
country is divided this case that
forced this decision dobbs was a case
that said that abortion should be legal
for 15 weeks
do you know whether you know what the
legal limit in germany is i know there
are 12 weeks right but they also have
western europe yes they also have health
care for everybody well that's fair
enough women are more likely to find out
that they're pregnant
they're more likely to have access to
the things that they need to get an
abortion or to keep the child but they
haggle it out and come to a compromise
with some restrictions and some freedoms
but that's what i'm talking about
there's no i mean the texas
republican party had their convention
this week
among the things they said i mean some
were fairly predictable for a red state
republican convention that the last
election is not legitimate which we get
used to but is
outrageous
secession
completely on the team go for it go for
it get rid of texas see that's
no no
no
it's a argument you can't get
rid of you're going to austin too oh
they can take austin
it's that's a i'm sorry it's a i guess
you're kidding i hope you're kidding
because first of all it's not possible
it's never going to happen well
i don't know half the country i read
last week in a poll thinks they will see
a civil war in their lifetime and when
that half i think a lot of them see a
civil war are rooting for one
i think a lot of them are actually
rooting for it whatever it is they also
listen to this
uh homosexuality they said is an
abnormal lifestyle i mean so we're back
to the 80s on that
this is the country they want clarence
thomas put it in the ruling today we are
going back to and i'm telling you this
is two different countries
yeah but on the issues like abortion say
let's take that
this is actually a great opportunity for
liberals for pro-choice pro-choices the
country is not in favor of banning all
abortion only 13 want that so go out
there
persuade people and what what this
ruling does is call the religious rights
bluff they've always been able to say
this is terrible must be banned they've
never had to face the consequences of
such a ban and now they will make the
argument build the coalitions win the
elections in the states and get
pro-choice policies back
you